Hay cosas que en pleno siglo
21 no deberían seguir existiendo
en 1 país donde la mayor parte de su población,
especialmente la más joven,
rechaza cualquier tipo de espectáculo donde se torture
y se asesine a 1 pobre animal inocente.
Decir que cuando 1 animal muere
ahogado en su propia sangre
tras toda 1 suerte de torturas
ante 1 turba que vitorea
y alcanza el clímax con el desmembramiento
del pobre herbívoro.
Decir que eso es 1 expresión cultural
da idea del primitivismo
en la que 1 parte de la sociedad aún se mueve
y por eso es tan necesaria esta LP
promovida por la plataforma
no es mi cultura para derogar la ley 18,
23 desde podemos nos sumamos a parar ya esta barbarie
y vamos a poner todas nuestras sedes
y a toda nuestra militancia
a disposición para la recogida de firmas,
pero sobre todo a concienciar a la sociedad
en el bienestar animal y en los derechos
de todos esos seres
que comparten con nosotras este bello planeta.
El maltrato animal en cualquier variante
nunca puede ser cultura